[Music]
so many high school students went viral
for sharing
that big moment you know getting
accepted into the college of your dreams
and now we're chatting it up with a few
of our viral faves
about where they're headed this fall you
got in
you got in
has it sunk in how has this college
acceptance experience been for you
honestly it's been crazy i didn't think
i was gonna get in i was very
like anxious and then just to get that
relief of that
i actually got in was just so amazing
and i just felt so proud of myself
a lot of incredible people went to
howard including
our very own vp kamala harris knowing
that our
current vice president is an alumni
for howard university i
oh give me the chill i'm so honored and
blessed now your college
acceptance video it's all over the webs
what were you feeling in that exact
moment
um a lot of shock my mom was like
speaking to me but like
her words were not processing in my
brain it was like she was saying stuff
but i was like
i'm like reading it over and over again
like oh
my gosh i was like shaking i couldn't
cry couldn't scream i didn't know what
to do with my body
what is the best piece of advice someone
has given you
as you graduate one of the best advices
that i've
ever gotten is definitely for my mom she
reminds me just to keep going like
don't stop
[Music]
i am a first generation college goer so
my parents were
very ecstatic i think they would have
been fine with me getting into
any school but you know and we saw the
yes from all the prestigious schools
such as harvard
it was definitely meant for a lot of
screams and tears of joy
[Music]
colombia brown
dartmouth harvard
stephanie you've been accepted to
multiple ivy league schools like
what what has this college acceptance
experience been like for you
it was a year that was very uncertain i
applied
to 23 schools i was admitted to 20 total
but it was a very exciting year what do
you think makes for a strong application
i think my application was strong in the
fact that i had a lot of community
service
because you know my future career
hopefully i want to be an attorney
i'm a pro bono training at that so i
think my community service
that i was doing right now definitely um
helped them accept
are me kidding me are you actually
kidding me
i'm we're going to tennessee let's see
we are going to tennessee
why was tennessee your dream school
why that school i just
love the college
and they gave me a chance
i going to decided to take that chance
the
fact that i would be the first one to
actually
complete and graduate college in my
family
and i have acc too
doctors never said he'd function in life
he wouldn't be able to talk
he wouldn't be able to walk and he has
overcome
everything that he has put his mind to
um
done everything that he could possibly
[Music]
do
[Music]
congratulations maha thank you so much
it's kind of like a dream as you saw i
was like shaking and i was like oh my
goodness this is not real
i had to make sure it was like my name
written on it what does this moment mean
to you
coming from my parents working hard my
mom taking two jobs my dad working day
and night
they kind of put our education first
coming from like a public school in
illinois
where like these things don't really
happen for us it was like
not just the hard work of my parents but
my school i could see my teachers be
like
you know she did it what do you hope
that people who watch your
viral moment you know like we were
saying it's such a beautiful and genuine
moment
that you know just an ordinary citizen
with
their family just so happen to catch in
that moment what do you hope people
take away when they watch my parents are
immigrants we're first gen students we
come from very humble backgrounds
and it's like you are capable and you
can do this and i want these kids to
know that when they watch these videos
that
they wherever they are they have a
chance
and they should never like limit
themselves unless they have a chance to
take it and they should
my name is mahazi my name is olivia
ximenez
hi i'm kevin nager my name is stephanie
utteras
and i got into harvard university and
i'll be going
into the future program at the
university of tennessee i am going to
harvard
and i got into howard university
yay
you